Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We're here in day one of the seven-day soulclubs, which will probably be
70-day soulclubs or whatever that will allow us to do here as
We break this down and taking this actually from a
series of sermons that I did years ago and trying to break them down and just to
To very small bite-sized pieces. So I'm going to make my best effort to do that
so it may be
a
Little abrupt endings and pickups throughout these days, but I'm trying to make them so that
people can listen to them and digest little pieces at a time
Instead of having to be a long-serving that less people will listen to and I pray that tell you
You take these words of mine. No, that I'm just a man. I'm not a
pastor or a preacher or a doctor or a teacher and
That you ask that the Holy Spirit utilize this information in your life or your loved ones life to
to
regurgitate and teach you the way he wants you to and
Forgive me for errors and mistakes and for him to convert those to truce and you need to grow and become more
like in a daily basis
So with that let's get started with day one again. We're talking if this is all based upon
Matthew the book of Matthew that we're going to go through and I started this basically
Tell you in the intro if you listen to that that really Matthew 5-3 is really been kind of my life verse and
partly
My draw to it is I know that it's the Holy Spirit drawing me to this, but my draw to this has been that
From an introduction to this that this is really the first words of Jesus Christ
That is that is recorded for us
His servant on the Mount
Now I know that prior to the servant on the board about historically that Jesus was baptized by John
Many words were spoken that he went to a wedding at Canaan and words were spoken and the different
Gospels talk about that way. Matthew doesn't and and that there are other teachings and callings because
He called his apostles prior to this so
teachings were made but as we read through the Gospels
This is really his first recorded message to us that we see and I think there's
an appropriateness of that that
Blessed are the poor and spirit and we're going to break that down sometime in the future
But quickly that word poor is the Greek word Tocos which means come to be completely destitute and
Where my heart has been broken with this verse is that the real understanding of it for me is that God is saying
Those that understand that they are completely utterly destitute
Without a relationship with Christ
Are the ones that are going to continue the kingdom of heaven later we hear that
It's only if we enter like a child that we could even enter into the kingdom of heaven and this verse speaks to it
It would take all our knowledge and throw it out the door take all our goodness and throw it out the door
Take all of our religion with all of its works and throw it out the door
It's only when we come completely dependent upon the power and the grace and the mercy of Jesus Christ
Like a little child
Completely dependent upon his mother for feeding or he's going to starve to death
Will we ever really see the truth will we ever be able to enter into the kingdom of heaven?
It's not by our works
It's not by our great knowledge. It's not by our intelligence. It's not by our knowing
scripture and knowing doctrine though
There's importance to that and we need to grow up in our relationship with the Lord
We're commanded to do that so that we can share the truth as other people that that we can we could grow in that relationship and become mature
But we don't enter it that way we enter it completely dependent upon him
His grace and his mercy in order to give that to us and with that is our introduction to Matthew
So why the book of Matthew?
Why are there four gospels?
So really in my understanding there are four gospels because it gives us four different
Perspectives or photographs of Jesus Christ not just from a historical standpoint, but when we look at God in his
His
Ways to understand him and we're going to spend eternity
Getting to know our heavenly Father the gospel gives us four different perspectives the book of John portrays
Jesus Christ as the son of God who always was God and always will be God
He says
The word the beginning was the word and the word is God and the word always was God
That that word is the word logos in the beginning was the logos, which is that intelligence of creation
It was Jesus who created all things it is Jesus who sustains all things who sustains every single cellular
function in order for me to survive in order for me to have any ability to speak to you right now and share any truth
It is only by the grace of God that that takes place
And I'm astounded by my own flesh sometimes
And I hear this from patients quite often too that
We want things from God and we did we think that we could even demand things from God
because
of our great past or because of the way we pray and
Somebody's the other day saying I don't think God is hearing me
My prayed all the time, but I don't think he hears me and
And I was just like I think that way sometimes too and it's like how narcissistic are we
That we think we can demand from God and pray for what we want and when he doesn't give us what we want
Well, he must not be hearing me or maybe I need a secret way to say it
Maybe I need to have a little twain in my voice and say well, Jesus healed me or something like that
And then God will give me what I looked
Isn't that what life is as as I see what I wanted
And it says in the book of James that if you don't pray and ask God you don't have because you ask not
But how often do we ignore the second part of that passage that it says
basically
When we ask in the spirit and in through the will of God
God doesn't it doesn't Santa Claus
He's not there to just give us everything that we wanted life
Um
And I'll admit I do that too, but honestly most of my prayers and my prayer time is not for the for that I'm healed of my
Diseases or by cancer or my financial woes or my struggles
I ask that for that. I think that's right to ask for healing
But most of my prayer time is spent
Asking God to shape me and mold me to the image of his son through this thing
That he's sobered. He's allowed this cancer in my life to shape me
And I want him to do his work in me so that I become a different person because of this and have the desires that he desires
And that's my prayer Lord put your desires in my heart
So that I may
Display you to those that I bump into more readily instead of my narcissistic self coming out
And I just pray that that be your prayer with that too
God is
Through Jesus Christ. This is stator of every single
Cellular function that takes place millions of cellular functions that it can take place moment by moment in every single
Cell of our body in order for life to even exist and yet we in our narcissism could come and think that we could
Demand from God. There wasn't for him. We wouldn't even exist
At a moment to moment basis. We should be on our knees praising him
That we have another day to to experience his love and to show his love to other people
um
Yet we lied and we cry because we don't get our work like a bunch of girls sometimes
And I do too
So that's the book of John
The book of Luke
portrays Christ as son of man
One who is fully God yet he's fully man mysteriously one who
Tasted every affliction that we could taste
one who
relates to every wound one who relates to every disease one who relates to every
How we that we could have
Experiencing every emotion yet over coming every sin. He is our perfect covenant
Representative and when we are in him
We experience all that he is when we are in him
We experience even his pain and his sufferings and we could say like Paul
And I may I may suffer as Christ to fully experience everything that he's experienced
But then if those who are truly in him
Then we have when we have taken up our cross and we really experience Calvary
We are also co-resorrected in him
His he is our covenant representative
He is fully man but yet fully God the book of Mark portrays
Christ as our servant king
He is the servant he has come to be our servant to serve mankind
But the book of Matthew is different it portrays Christ as
King it portrays Christ in a position that is overall
And though done of these individual attributes and all the other millions of attributes
Of God and of Christ character are more important than any other one Matthew is
Different
Because Matthew not only portrays a part of Christ's character
It it demands it insight
It really the book of Matthew is really a call to reality the book of Matthew is really written to the Jewish people
And and when we could we could intellectually in our knowledge really testify to his deity
Yes, I believe that God
Jesus Christ is God and he was always
Coexisted with the father the creator of the stator of all things we could admit to his humanity yes he came in the flesh
And and became man so that he could be our true covenant representative
What he died in the cross in his blood was shed he could be our perfect covenant representative to the father
To create that new covenant that we may walk in and have from give to sin forever
And we could agree to his servanthood
Oh, we all look that we we want a
God that is going to meet our needs and take care of us and prepare a plan
For us who but when when he demands to be king of our life
We could easily have a problem with that
It is really a call to reality because it's a revelation really of my pretending and what I dig him to this book
I am confronted strongly
With the masks in my life
The the pretenses that I've created
So as we begin this somewhat arduous task of beginning to see him as he is
There's going to be I think
Several reactions that are going to take place in my heart at different times and to those who are listening to this
number one
Mask or masks are going to come off
Which to some people is going to lead to maybe
Sometimes I'm going to be very uncomfortable with this teaching
Sometimes I might I might even be embarrassed as I really am reflecting my life and the kind of how I act a lot
Um, I might be ashamed
Because this this Jesus that I thought I do
Uh, this Jesus that I kind of safely clung to this Jesus that done that I accepted so long ago
Isn't how is the Jesus that I really see its scripture when the Holy Spirit
Uncomers him
It reveals to me
That I really isn't my king today
And though this revelation can be embarrassing and sometimes filled with pain and sometimes filled with tears
I think it can be it can be freed
And I just pray that it is freeing to you
I think there's going to be some that are going to be set free when they're here in this
Uh, I have been and I am on a daily basis
And more than anybody who reads this and listens to me here, I'm teaching myself
And I'm asking the Holy Spirit reveal this truth to be on a deeper level on a daily basis
Because I need my religious baggage to go away
And uh, I need that to drop off
And sometimes when that happens, I'm going to experience tears and mourning
And we're going to read that and
At you five four blessed are those who mourn the grieve over their sin
They're the ones that are going to be receiving comfort
So when that sin is relieved it is revealed in our life and when
Christ not being king is revealed in my life
There can be some anger that comes out there can be some bitterness that comes out and you might turn this off right away
Because you don't want to hear that truth
And we've spent so much time building our own little kingdom and listening to self-help things and reading self-help
Box and trying to build up our self-esteem so strongly that would
The revelation that God comes into our life or that Jesus Christ needs to be our king
It's not very comfortable but sometimes
But I pray it sets you free
Secondly, it can reveal our pretenses
Frankly, I don't think that you're going to find this real worm breeze and a gentle stroke of kindness
when we um, before a Pharisee
So for stoking our religious
religious
dogmas
doctrines and we start hearing things that Jesus needs to be the king of our life
um, it can it can uh, it can reveal our pretenses
and
We like that find this to be all warm and cozy
When we start to hear too hard of teachings like this and we might find ourselves walking away
From this truth about Jesus kind of saying things like um kind of like his followers did in John
660 and so an unword from there that this is too hard and so many of his disciples left him
This this teaching is too hard, you know
We came for the goody goody things and we came for the healings and we all want that
We all want that kind of God who's going to feed us and it's going to
It's going to take away our pain and our suffering. We want that kind of God
But will you start saying things like beauty tip
To to eat my body and drink my blood and take up your cross on a daily basis. Well, who wants to hear that kind of stuff
I came for the the nice stuff. I came for I'm the one indeed here
And we can walk away from this Jesus quite easily
This stuff is too deep this stuff is too much
But I pray if if this is where you are now that
That you hold on to this just like Peter did because later in those verses in John 6
Jesus says to his disciples are you guys going to leave too
And Peter is the one who spoke up and basically said
Where would we go
We don't have any other place to go
Besides we don't get it all we don't understand everything
But we just know that you are the son of God
And and I don't understand I don't get this whole picture, but just heal my unbelief
So with that, let's turn to the book of Matthew
And we're going to do that in day two
Let's start reading who is this God that sent his son where did he come from as we're going to read through this very
on and skipped
Sections of the Bible called genealogies that mean nothing to us today
But
When we when we get into this we're going to see how in the book of Matthew it's going to be a confrontation
To the spiritual religious knowledge of the day
Thank you